in northern ethiopia artillery and
troops race down the highways
thousands of armed combatants moving at
speed as the ethiopian army trades blows
with fighters from the restive region of
tigray
the country's leader abi ahmed has
launched a major offensive but his
forces have made little progress
we watched them heading east after
losing ground in a region called afar
and they've attacked the tigrayan
capital michele from the air with a
strike that was described to us as heavy
it follows an aerial assault two days
ago on what the ethiopian government
called communications facilities
the un says three children were killed
as this 10-month conflict tips into
civil war humanitarian agencies have
become increasingly alarmed the people
of tigre says the un are facing a
humanitarian catastrophe
they're trying to send a hundred trucks
a day with emergency aid from afar to
tigray
but the terrain and local residents are
hostile
this road is desolate and the people who
use it are preyed on by bandits and
venal police officers but the food
convoys are particularly vulnerable
they're the object of a huge amount of
local resentment
it's a two-day drive to the border and
the world food program are struggling we
saw just a few vehicles trickle into
tigre
good
but the drivers are taking a chance in
the region of afar where few support
these convoys
are you worried about coming back
the afaris are angry blaming tigrayan
fighters for a series of deadly attacks
and they made their displeasure known
they kill us they kill us not we we kill
them they kill us when they kill us we
are helping them now or
they are using this way this way we are
not stopping we are not closing any road
this is our border they are killing us
we are we are supporting them
we asked and were refused permission to
cross this internal frontier
but the commander of a special forces
unit took us up to the front line
the problems with their leaders the tpls
not the people of tigre he said
and from this spot on the mountaintop
the tplf are close by it's just 20
kilometers to mckele
but that doesn't worry the commander
very much
it may not prove as simple as that in a
region scarred by war we found 400 men
living under trees after they'd been
displaced from their homes by the
fighting how long have you been here
three months he said
they're upset with their neighbors into
grey and those trying to help them the
resentment close to the surface
a regional conflict is now a national
crisis which the country's leaders seem
unable to solve
and the lives of millions of ethiopians
are at stake
you